the cameras caught you counting to four
on your hands i wonder if that had
anything to do with uh with your ranking
in the nfl top 100 this off season
uh i think there's like four touchdowns
in the game i think at that point
sure it was sure look at that grin from
patrick my home sure that's what he was
referring to i mean last year against
the bears and mitchell trubisky
he counted to 10 on his fingers he
didn't throw 10 touchdown passes that
game
the point was i was the 10th overall
pick and
trubisky was the second overall pick so
he's got a way
of sending a message guys that is uh
not i mean he can get away with it it's
not offensive
right it doesn't spark outrage from
talk show hosts all day long he's got a
charming way about him there he is one
two three four the little jordan shrug
on the back end
and he can do it he's got the natural
charisma to get away with it all right
uh so uh let's see if patrick mahomes
name
comes up as we do our awards we say
hello first to mds who joins us for the
awards segment mds how are you
i'm doing well mike thanks for having me
as always
good to have you as always shireen and i
have been working our way through the
news
and some re-watch of the bills rams game
now we get to our awards and we're going
to start as we always do with the
offensive player of the week
mds you're up first well i'm going to
pick a guy
we've definitely never picked before and
that's nick mullins the 49ers
quarterback who
has now filled in for jimmy garoppolo
not just this year but also in 2018
really not missing a beat at all he
played very well for the giants he also
played
actually probably a little better than
garoppolo played in 2018 when
the whole 49ers team was really
struggling uh
you know nick mullins came into the nfl
as an undrafted rookie
he's never had an opportunity to be a
starter except when garoppolo
is hurt but i kind of hope he gets a
chance one day i think he's pretty
talented
and uh you know he went went to southern
miss and broke some of
brett favre's records and he played real
well
on sunday i like nick mullins and i'm
glad we can recognize him here because i
don't think he gets enough recognition
for what he does as a backup quarter
not some of the records he broke all the
records now maybe he didn't break the
interception record
but he broke all of the good records of
brett favre at southern miss
brett favre however was never a super
bowl mvp
shireen's offensive player of the week
can
can say that he was a super bowl mvp
shereen tell us who you picked
i picked nick foles the greatest backup
arguably in nfl history earl morrill of
course was nfl mvp when he came in
as a back up one year led a team to a
super bowl was
very good in the year the dolphins
undefeated season after bob griese got
hurt 11 straight wins he had
so those are two top backups probably in
nfl history but nick foles came in and
did what nick foles does as a backup
he won a game 20 points in the fourth
quarter was very very good
um the question becomes can he do it as
a starter he's only started 11 games
in a season that's the most he's ever
had
yeah and look it's inevitable that he's
going to get banged up at some point if
he gets hit like he did on sunday we'll
see how that plays out they need to have
mitchell trubisky ready to go just in
case
i look we're giving patrick mahomes more
fodder to count on his fingers or give
us one of the four fingers
if he gets the chance to do so for his
performance last night he's not mine
either none of us picked him i'm going
with russell wilson how can you not go
with russell wilson five touchdown
passes
14 in three games the most anyone has
ever thrown through three games of an
nfl season
the first player to ever have four or
more in three consecutive games to start
the season
he was incredible against the cowboys he
did whatever needed to be done
he throws that beautiful deep ball sims
and i broke that down today
and he would have had six potentially if
dk metcalf doesn't pull it to sean
jackson near the goal line in the first
half so
russell wilson uh mvp favorite but a lot
of football still to be played all right
defensive player of the week mds who do
you have
i have the nfl's leader in sex
and that is alden smith a player who
i i think most of us thought his career
was over
for about three or four years and
now aldon smith has come back and he's
not just come back he's come back and
he's the same player
he was at his best in san francisco
when he was one of the best players in
the nfl i mean he is an
outstanding pass rusher we really saw it
uh on sunday against seattle and i i
just think it's
it's great to see it's a tribute to him
that he's worked hard on himself
uh i think the cowboys deserve credit
for giving him that second chance
and they are really getting a reward for
it now
yeah i agree with that he was homeless a
year ago and it's amazing to think what
he could have been if he had played
continuously because he's right where he
was
2011 2012 averaging more than one sack
per game
four sacks in three games and he
affected that game throughout he was
always around the football
impressive comeback by him and hopefully
he keeps it up shereen who do you have
well patrick mahomes may be even more
mad now but you got to get some love to
that chief's defense we want to talk
about all those offensive weapons that
the chiefs had and their quarterback and
everything else but chris jones and that
defense was outstanding and i'm giving
it to chris jones five tackles two sacks
two force fumbles
uh the team had four total sacks of
lamar
uh jackson and held them to 228 total
yards i just thought it was an
outstanding performance by that chief's
defense i didn't see that coming at all
i think
everyone thought this was going to be a
high scoring game by both teams and it
wasn't
yeah and and he had that one moment
where he got flagged for illegal hands
to the face
and he popped the guy's helmet off and
then the
the head covering he ripped that off too
in the same motion that takes some
dexterity to pull that off so
uh chris jones uh money well spent by
the kansas city chief to keep him around
all right
look i i i was gonna go erin donald but
he'd be the defensive player of the week
every week we praised him earlier in the
program
i want to give some love to the
cleveland browns they're two-in-one and
and even though
the stat sheet doesn't scream this out
carl joseph is a guy you have to watch
out for in the brown secondary he had an
interception
that really helped swing momentum in
cleveland's way and also
uh i i i think that uh you know he had
one of the hits of the week he blew a
guy up along the sidelines so
let's give the browns a little love i'll
give it to carl joseph this week all
right let's move on to rookie of the
week
mds who do you have i have
justin jefferson the vikings wide
receiver who
looked like a real bright spot now the
vikings offense has been
a mess for most of this season
so far certainly the first two games it
started to come on
here in week three the vikings still
lost but we started to see what they can
do
and justin jefferson was huge he had 175
receiving yards if minnesota is going to
turn this offense
around and turn this season around i
think he might be the key to it
trading away stefan diggs so far is not
looking like a great decision but if
justin jefferson can keep playing like
that
maybe we can start to say okay that
wasn't a bad decision
because they found the right guy to
replace him yeah now
now he's got a guy you got to account
for and maybe it helps open up the rest
of that passing game the first couple of
weeks they didn't have that guy that was
attracting the extra attention so that's
a good choice by you shireen who do you
have
well i'm gonna go with gabriel davis and
if you don't know who gabriel davis is
you didn't watch that bill's rams game
he's a fourth round draft pick for the
bills he had four catches for 81 yards
and they all came after john brown
went out he had to come in and play and
the biggest play of the game was not a
catch
it was that dpi in the end zone that on
fourth down that gave the bill's new
life and they scored the winning
touchdown on the play after that but a
huge game by gabriel davis
just made one outstanding catch over the
shoulder on the sideline got both feet
down
he just looked really really good i
think he's going to be a steal of this
draft
and i first noticed him last week when
he made an incredible diving catch in
the end zone
in the loss or the win excuse me over
the miami dolphins
and yeah you throw him into the mix with
colby's lee stefan diggs and john brown
you got a hell of a receiving core
in buffalo for me it's james robinson
even though his rushing numbers
for the jaguars on thursday night were
not tremendous
you know it was a game where it felt
like the entire jaguars team
was in quicksand except for him he had
46 rushing yards and a couple of
touchdowns
plus six catches on six targets for 83
yards he was their offense
without dj shark and he was the spark
that was there all night long
and if the other 10 players on offense
played like him all night long
they would have won that game this guy
was undrafted out of illinois state
proving yet again you don't need to use
a first round pick or a second round
pick or any round pick on a running back
if you can scout well and find a guy
who can come in you trust him not to
fumble you trust him in pass protection
when blitzers break through and if you
can open some holes for him
he's going to gain some yards and james
robinson getting it done all right coach
of the week mds who do you have
i have matt nagy and in hindsight maybe
benching mitch trubisky for nick poles
looks like an easy call but the reality
is it's never
easy to make that decision with all the
resources that the bears have poured
into mitch trubisky
the draft pick the trade up to number
two the time
and energy matt maggie has put into
building mitch trubisky into the
quarterback for his system
but he decided at the right time i've
seen enough and it's time to make a
change and he did it
in time to come back and win sunday's
game against the falcons
and now the bears are 3-0 and there's a
lot of optimism
in chicago for where this team can go
sharian who do you have
i have sean mcdermott i mean this game
could have gone one of two ways
after they lost that 25 point lead it
didn't
and this was huge and i think it's going
to be a
point we're going to look back on this
season and say this was really a turning
point for the bills they figured out
their really good football team
and i'm going kyle shanahan 11 starters
not available for sunday's game against
the giants they shredded the giants the
week before they shredded the jets and i
know
that it's the jets and the giants but
they haven't been relegated to the xfl
yet they are still full-fledged members
of the nfl and to go across the country
stay in west virginia all week go back
to us to a stadium where
the players have misgivings about
playing on the surface and the win is
convincingly as they did with all those
backups in the game
the ultimate next man up coach right now
is cal shanahan
a lot like bill belichick so uh he gets
the award this week
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports